parent
salut à tous bienvenue à sainte anne
cette semaine on vous parle d'une
discipline qui compte une vingtaine de
clubs 3 ligues des galas des
manifestations pratiquement tous les
mois
et pour nous en parler la victoire au ta
passion c'est quoi david le muay thaï
c'est parti david est ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier de grand frère un professeur
de muay thaï une discipline fortement
ancrée dans l'est avec trois clubs à
sainte-anne et 5 à saint benoît il et
d'ajouter voilà il donna une
responsabilité en même temps une
valorisation
là on fait le bilan l'aps au tibet vous
étiez là mais ça c'est déjà créer une
cohésion parce qu'il n'ya pas que
l'entraînement en salle qui crée
cohésion parce que je devais donner aux
autres ce que j'ai à donner et pour
qu'ils n'aillent pas sur le même chemin
que moi je connais
et chaque soir c'est le même rituel
récupérer le matériel et direction le
gymnase
mais là encore c'est loin d'être gagné
bonsoir et salut
bon ben on on va fé l'ont tellement à
l'extérieur et est ce que ce n'est pas
ton poids une entraînement à l'extérieur
un gymnase en travaux un détail pour se
passer de médailles
david a simplement dit vous êtes
partants et c'est parti tâchons de
savoir ce qui les motive
sa femme jo travail gauche droite genou
roche genre 3 finit avec gauche droite
le monopole d'une égalisation l'armée
liem med le camp lmp par bataille de
chemin
alors depuis m e pons critiques et
propositions
évidemment qu on puisse confiance et
mais dans mon corps aussi
j'ai été la première arrivée au site
game assez on suit les avis sont venus
je pense que comme monde y est ça la
venue d'une fille a permis aux autres de
venir ça les intéressait aussi on
regarde tous les gens qui sont motivés
mais je pense que on aura de bons
salaires à une salle pendant ce temps
une salle déjà pour s'entraîner et
poteau le fera ici surtout dans l'est on
a l'appui tout quoi on va faire un petit
exercice à poil et ce qu'ils travaillent
et esquivent les réflexes
chez nous